I saw the whale  I made one mistake watching that movie  is not bringing any tissue I was a  complete mess at the end of the movie  and I walked out of the theater and I  was on the phone for two hours calling  everybody that I know  and I said you have got to see this  movie that's what it comes out that's  good I was just blown away by a  performance Brandon I really you know  because we go way back we go yeah uh we  work together on a movie called Encino  Man in the 90s  we're still here that's awesome yeah  yeah yeah you broke me with that line we  saw each other out there for the first  time after all these years we gave each  other a hug and uh and he said key was  still here ah we're still here  we took a vote and the computer Club  feels your presence will be a valuable  asset to our organization